in the 3 to 4 hours since Google Gemini
has been announced I've read the full
60-page technical report the attached
Alpha code to fascinating technical
report and all the media interviews
clips and press releases that Google
have put out I've got 45 notes so I'm
going to skip the long intro and get
straight to it here is the paper Gemini
a family of Highly capable multimodal
models and let's get one thing out of
the way straight away is this AGI no is
it better than GPT 4 yes in many
modalities but in text it's probably a
draw are many people going to overlook
the bombshell Alpha code 2 paper
probably anyway it's three models Ultra
Pro and Nano Nano being for your phone
Pro being the rough equivalent of GPT
3.5 or slightly better and Ultra being
released early next year as the GPT 4
competitor now the first paragraph of
both that technical report and this
accompanying web page tout its abilities
in the MML and I must say in the web
page they were gunning for maximum hype
because they had this human expert level
here and they had Gemini being the first
model to beat it the first problem that
you might have noticed is that GPT 4
score was done five shots basically it
was given five examples to learn from
before answering each question whereas
Gemini Ultra the biggest model was done
Chain of Thought with 32 samples this is
not the video to go into Chain of
Thought or self-consistency but it's a
different way of measuring it's not an
Apples to Apples comparison and in the
appendix of the technical report we'll
see a genuine comparison also I've had
many conversations with the creators of
the MML as I was doing my smart GPT
video and that figure of
89.8% is very approximate the 10-second
summary of the mlu is that it's a
multiple choice test across 57 different
subjects from chemistry to business to
mathematics to morality and
unfortunately Demis aabis engaged in
some of that hype with this remark
what's amazing about Gemini is that it's
so good at so many things as we started
getting to the end of the training uh we
started seeing that Gemini was better
than any other model out there on these
very very important benchmarks for
example each of the 50 different subject
areas that we tested on um it's as good
as the best expert humans in those areas
so no Gemini Ultra and GPT 4 can't be
most human experts and while they
describe the MML U as one of the most
popular methods to test the knowledge
and problem solving abilities of AI
models they don't actually try to back
up its credibility if you watch my
second smart GPT video I showed how with
some basic prompt scaffolding you can
reach 89% with GPT 4 and frankly if we
had a slightly larger budget than the
couple thousand in API calls that we
used we could have reached 90% with GPT
4 furthermore it's somewhat ridiculous
to Showcase these results to one decimal
place when the test itself has maybe 2
to 3% of its questions being in error if
you want more details check out that
video but it's quite egregious I
actually spoke with anthropic another
leading AGI lab about this and they did
a blog post on the errors in this test
so the fact that months after that
Google is still touting results on this
test is a little surprising to me that's
not to say that Gemini Ultra isn't the
best new model I think it is it's just
weird that they picked this particular
Benchmark and deep in the appendix of
the paper Google she ially gives a
slightly more reasonable comparison
between the two models on these text
questions as you can see depending on
the prompting strategy you get different
results and please forgive me for one
last bit of mockery of the two decimal
places they give here when 2 to 3% of
the test contains errors very briefly
though before we get back to the paper
many of you might be wondering what are
these kind of techniques that can boost
performance well I was intending to
launch this slightly later on but now is
as good a time as any it's my new AI
insiders content on patreon and no I'm
not going to do a long ad we'll be back
to Gemini in 30 seconds I've been
working on this for months doing
interviews with Google deepmind people
like Jim fan Microsoft authors basically
creating the best possible exclusive
content that I could come up with and
the reason I mention it now is because
in one of these exclusive videos I talk
with a top Google author about the
future of prompting it's not this one
although I'm really proud of that one
reasoning as the holy Gray of llms not
this one I think it was this one I spoke
to shing Chen Juan about this evolution
of prompting there is much more content
coming and I'm even going to have a
feature where you can vote on what kind
of questions I ask the next round of
experts some of whom will feature later
in this video on Google Gemini but why
do I say in other modalities it beats
GPT 4 well look at this in nine of nine
image understanding benchmarks it beats
GPT 4 vision and all other models six of
six video standing benchmarks and five
of five speech recognition and speech
translation benchmarks that's not bad
they are trained to support a 32,000
token context window which compares to
128,000 for GPT 4 Turbo with anthropic
you can get up to 200,000 tokens but the
performance isn't quite as good
interestingly they did tell us the
parameter count of the Nano models at
1.8 billion parameters and 3.25 billion
parameters they even give us the detail
that they are 4bit quantized or
distilled down smaller versions of the
larger Gemini models what about other
key details like the data set they used
well as you might have guessed they say
we plan to update this report with more
details ahead of the general
availability of the Gemini Ultra model
and later on they go into fantastic
detail but not really saying our
pre-training data set uses data from web
documents super helpful books and code
and includes image audio and and video
data great instead of detail on the data
set we do get this incredible nugget
some of the delay to Gemini was due to
external factors such as cosmic rays now
obviously I'm being factious but that is
an interesting detail now one key detail
that I mentioned back in the Palm 2
video was this case of positive transfer
essentially by training the model on
image audio as well as text and video
they got positive transfer in other
words the model got better at text by
being trained on images as Google keeps
saying it was trained from the ground up
to be multimodal and that's why it gets
such good results in other modalities
which I'll get to in fact here they are
pretty much state-of-the-art across
natural image understanding document
understanding infographic understanding
it's even better in video captioning
video question answering speech
translation but these are solid results
this is nothing to do with prompting it
genuinely is a better model in these
modalities remember though that we're
not getting the ultra until early next
year and at the moment Pro and Nano can
only respond with text and code they
can't yet do what you're seeing in all
of these demos which I'll get to in a
second which is generate images speaking
of the release though people in the UK
and EU like me aren't even getting
Google Gemini on launch apparently it's
about regulations so time will tell this
is the kind of interactive UI that I
mean and it does look good clicking on
the interface regenerates the data to be
rendered by the code at Route oh I know
she likes cupcakes I can now click on
anything in the interface and ask it for
more information I could say stepbystep
instructions on how to bake this and it
starts to generate a new UI this time it
designs an UI best suited for giving me
step-by-step instructions but now time
for some of the highlights and I'm going
to start with the one that I was most
impressed by because because of Gemini's
ability to understand Nuance information
and answer questions relating to
complicated topics it can give you a
customized explanation of the subject
you're trying to learn and lastly if you
want to learn more you can just
ask Gemini will provide personalized
practice problems based on
mistakes here I have a similar problem
where I have to figure out the cat speed
the height of the r is
double
oh yeah I knew that now I'm not naive
enough to think that Google Gemini won't
sometimes hallucinate answers but this
format of providing follow-up questions
understanding messy handwriting and
tying all together is pretty impressive
the paper makes a great point that
because it was trained from the ground
up to be multimodal it doesn't take
audio and then put it into text where
you lose some Nuance like tone for
languages like Mandarin which I've
studied in China that's super important
as this demo demonstrat wres how to
pronounce the word Luna January in
Chinese option A J option b Jung which
one is correct which tongue is the
correct tongue for the first character
option A the first character is
pronounced with the first tone Gemini
was able to differentiate the two ways
of pronouncing the word to make sure it
was correct and speaking of video
understanding these two demos weren't
bad
either you were trying to get me to find
find the paper ball under the cup I
accept the
challenge the cup to the
left
nice what movie are they acting out here
I think they are acting out the famous
bullet time scene from The Matrix ooh
nice what do you think might happen next
the cat is going to jump to the wall and
stick The Landing it's going to be a
perfect
10 oh and it's a miss it looks like it
was just a little too far away but don't
worry the cat is a natural athlete and
it will be back up there in no time
going back to languages for a second we
see from this machine translation
Benchmark which couldn't have been in
the training data by the way that Gemini
Ultra beat Palm to large but why is
beating Palm to large so significant
well I covered this at the time but in
certain settings we observe that Palm 2
improves quality both over palm and
Google translate and Gemini Ultra is an
improvement on Palm to large so expect
the multilingual performance to be next
level now what about coding well here's
where it's a draw in some ways and a
massive win for Gemini Ultra in other
ways natural 2 code was a heldout data
set with no leakage on the web so a
really good Benchmark to use and Gemini
Ultra beats gp4 Gemini Pro by the way
beats GPT 3.5 but yes the results are
fairly close a 1% % Point difference the
craziness though comes from the alpha
code 2 technical report this was also
released 3 to 4 hours ago now Alpha code
2 is based on Gemini Gemini Pro actually
not Gemini Ultra and it achieves truly
outstanding things that's not to say it
will be available to you anytime soon
it's very compute intensive but it does
show what is coming to the automation of
coding I'll try to get to as many
details as I can yes I have read this
report in full too Alpha code 2 based on
Gemini Pro was evaluated on the code
forces platform GPT 4 could solve zero
out of 10 of the easiest problems when
they were recent not within its data set
as this author points out that strongly
points towards contamination because it
could solve 10 out of 10 of the
pre-2020 of those problems within 10
attempts beating 85% of competition
participants now Alpha code 2 isn't just
one model it's an entire system they
basically get a family of Gemini models
by tweaking different hyperparameters
think of it as different flavors of
Gemini which generate code samples for
each problem it was important to have
those different flavors cuz they wanted
code diversity then they sampled
hundreds and up to a million code
samples to search over the space of
possible programs this is maybe what
Demis cabis mentioned when he talked
about Alpha go plus GPT in a video I did
a while back at this point you can see
why it's not yet for Consumer release
because that is incredibly compute
intensive anyway they then filtered out
the results to remove code that didn't
compile or didn't pass the unit tests
they also had a mechanism to filter out
code that was too similar but then
here's the interesting bit they used
Gemini as a scoring model to surface the
best candidate are you getting Vibes of
let's verify step by step from my qar
video if not I'm not hinting strongly
enough here's some more evidence they
used a fine-tuned Gemini pro model to
attribute an estimated correctness score
between 0 and 1 to code samples remember
from let's verify that evaluation is
easier than generation I'll have to
cover this in more detail in another
video because there's other juicy
nuggets to get into the ranking of alpha
code 2 on the test was between expert
and master in its best two performances
alphacode 2 outperforms more than
99.5% of competition participants here's
where it gets more interesting to solve
these level of problems before writing
the code implementation one needs to
understand analyze and reason about the
problem this explains why generally
available AI systems I think they mean
GPT 4 perform poorly on this Benchmark
Alpha code 2's success on this
competitive programming contest
represents an impressive step change
this is something I actually discussed
with Jim fan a senior AI researcher at
Nvidia for AI insiders and he quoted
mathematics being the first to fall and
I think that's one of the reasons why
coding and math look set to be the first
first to fall I'm not talking imminently
but if you can generate enough samples
and then test them it becomes more a
matter of compute rather than reasoning
root force over Beauty you can see here
how even with the number of samples
approaching a million the results keep
getting better they also note that the
sample efficiency of alpha code 2
because of the underlying model is a lot
better than Alpha code 1 I'm sure you
all want to try it and they say we are
working towards bringing Alpha code 2's
unique capabilities to our foundation
Gemini models but why can't we have it
here well they reiterate that just above
our system requires a lot of trial and
error and remains too costly to operate
at scale and many of you may have picked
up on another key detail I said they
used Gemini Pro maybe this was for
budgeting reasons but they say we
suspect using Gemini Ultra as the
foundation model instead with its
improved coding and reasoning
capabilities would lead to further
improvements in the overall all Alpha
code 2 approach they do try to give a
sliver of reassurance to human coders a
bit later on though they note that when
using Alpha code 2 with human coders who
can specify additional filtering
properties we score above the 90th
percentile that's a 5en increase and
they say optimistically we hope this
kind of interactive coding will be the
future of programming where programmers
make use of the highly capable AI models
as collaborative tools as always let me
know what you think in the comments some
more notes on the release of Gemini
before we get to the media round that
hassabis did first Gemini Nano is coming
to the pixel 8 Pro that's going to power
features like summarize and smart reply
honestly I wouldn't yet trust a 3.5
billion parameter model to reply to
anything but that's just me they say you
can expect in the coming months that
Gemini will be available in services
such as search ads Chrome and du AI in a
week though starting December 13th devs
and Enterprise customers can access
access Gemini Pro via the Gemini API in
Google AI Studio starting today Bard
will use a fine-tune version of Gemini
Pro in those 170 countries excluding the
UK and EU and even though I'm hearing
reports of people being disappointed
with Gemini Pro remember that's not the
biggest model that's Gemini Ultra Gemini
Pro is more like the original chaty PT
in my last video I already covered what
the delay was behind Gemini Ultra
they're basically doing more
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback especially for low resource
languages where it was apparently really
easy to jailbreak they also kind of
teased out this Bard advanc which I
suspect will be a subscription model and
they call it a new Cutting Edge AI
experience that gives you access to our
best models and capabilities starting
with ultra be very interesting to see
whether they pitch that higher lower or
the same as chat GPT Pro I'll be honest
I'll be buying it regardless assuming
it's available in the UK in terms of API
pricing we don't yet know but this new
New York Times article did point out
that during that crisis at openai Google
offered the same price to customers at
openai as their current open AI rate and
also offered Cloud credits and discounts
thrown in we'll have to see if that
still applies to Gemini Pro and Gemini
Ultra what about the future of Gemini
though Gemini 2.0 well Demis Aris the
CEO of Google deepmind gave us this clue
he said that Google Deep Mind is already
looking into how Gemini might be
combined with robotics to physically
interact with the world to become truly
multimodal you want to include touch and
tactile feedback and I can't resist
pointing out at this point that I spoke
to panag sanetti for AI insiders he is
the tech lead manager for rt2 and I also
spoke about this topic with many other
lead authors at Nvidia and elsewhere and
I hope that video will be out on AI
insiders before the end of this month in
this wired interview demisa sais also
strongly hinted that this work was
related to what qar might be about
further Evidence idence that this is the
direction that all the major AI labs are
heading toward when asked about that he
said we have some of the world's best
reinforcement learning experts who
invented some of this stuff and went on
we've got some interesting Innovations
we're working on to bring to Future
versions of Gemini and again like me he
is a somewhat understated Londoner so
that could be pretty significant in The
Verge he doubled down on that talking
about Gemini Ultra saying it's going to
get even more General than images video
and audio there's still things like
action and touch more like robotics over
time he says Gemini will get more senses
become more aware and he ended his media
round with this as we approach AGI
things are going to be different hasab
says we're going to gain Insanity points
is what Sam Alman said it's kind of an
active technology so I think we have to
approach that cautiously cautiously but
optimistically and on that note I want
to end the video and yes I'm super
excited about the rolling launch of AI
insiders which you can sign up to now
but I also also want to reassure my
long-standing audience for many of whom
$29 or even $25 is way too expensive for
them I totally respect that and for most
of my life it would have been too
expensive for me too so don't worry as
this video shows I will still be posting
as frequently on the main AI explain
Channel and for those who can join at
least for the next few weeks I'm going
to be writing a personal message of
thanks for joining AI insiders of course
I am also massively grateful for all of
those supporting me at the legendary
level you guys will still get my
personal updates and blog style posts so
that's Google Gemini definitely not the
last video from me on any of those
models but thank you so much for
watching this video and have a wonderful
day